ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi faremo
una delle cose che io amo di più al
mondo calcolate che quella che è la mia
nemesi che è il formaggio diventa una
delle cose che io amo di più nel momento
in cui questo diventa filante comunque
cosa andremo a fare la mozzarella in
carrozza pre di tutto ringrazio gli
amici di giallozafferano perché non
pensavo che fosse così facile per se
fosse una cosa si potesse mangiare
solamente al ristorante mentre invece
una cosa che fa in due secondi a casa
tua se la parete e non mi tagliate su
instagram diverrà a prendere il maligno
nel sonno
detto ciò partiamo con ingredienti per
fare la mozzarella in carrozza avremmo
bisogno di una mezza luna pane in
cassetta 5 muffa pangrattato farina 00
olio per friggere e salt mi raccomando
anche un gatto che si è lamentata da
rimpasto al vostro cane da che tra poco
di preparò la mozzarella in carrozza no
mia colombotto è perché ha fame è perché
nella rompicapi da tavole pure mangiare
ma non ha capito che chi comanda sono io
iniziamo la rivolta degli animali con le
cucine vogliono tutti la mia mozzarella
in carrozza
per prima cosa prendiamo la mozzarella
la mettiamo su un taglierino e tagliamo
delle fette più o meno un centimetro ma
mai fiordilatte cosa preferisci bufala
sai
ogni scusa ultimamente buona per andare
in campagna per enrico un saluto a paola
il mio gruppo preferito sono paola e
chiara paola francesca è presente allo
stadio quando fanno col che si fa la
parola fatemi sapere se ci sono altri
giochi con paola che si possono fare
oggi ore girare con un gatto sulla palla
una cosa importantissima da fare quando
si fanno le mozzarelle in carrozza è
evitare che la mozzarella sia umida come
possiamo dare a questa cosa scottex
adagiamo le nostre fette qua sopra
poniamo di un uomo i nostri fazzoletti
io la sento ancora un po umida altro
giro sto cercando di asciugarli in tutti
i modi possibili
infatti quello che suggerisce lo chef
che le prepara e di utilizzare
mozzarelle del giorno dopo in modo che
hanno meno liquido dentro ed è anche
motopesca secondo me per consumare non
sarei laica come non è più buona da
mangiare fresca capisce dove stia
andando cucina buttata per il sociale a
me verrebbe da dire che andiamo avanti
disponiamo la mozzarella al centro di
ogni singola fetta
a questo punto prendiamo una fetta
mettiamo sopra un'altra fetta è
importantissimo schiacciamo per andare a
unirli per bene fondamentale a questo
punto rifilare i bordi una tua 34 e
mangiare ogni singolo scarto
mi raccomando vita dei per il tipo di
grandezza il pane contenuto e forma che
voglio ottenere ho deciso che la cosa
migliore sarà a dividerlo in due
ammetterete per lungo per obliquo
ottenere due triangolini medio grandi
medio piccoli piccoli meglio piccoli
nonostate la mozzarella bisognerà
salarla bellissimo più buono passiamo al
impara tour ha fatta proprio come si
dovrebbe fare ma dopo servire ad occhio
si vuole apriamo le uova
se quindi sotto seguimi 123 fonti gusci
d'uovo ti perdona più croccante 4 così
se ti butti giù enrico da mentale farina
a fette ora mi raccomando fate andare a
farina comunque sono luogo non attacca
aiutandoci con delle forchette come
suggeriscono i grandi chef sta
cominciando ad atteggiarsi alla
coscienza fiondate triangolo dei casi i
miei nella obama me dovete rompere coi
ora in teoria dovrebbero fa tutti
sdraiati kemalista fabri così sai cosa
si sta veramente aprendo in questo
momento aveva grattato 12 o per ora vi
sopra il signor rosa pazzesco imparato
da loro quando togliete dal pan grattato
col coltello andata a compattare 12
tanto che poi lo dobbiamo rimettere
dentro attraverso però devi assaggiarlo
indiretti fa schifo perché se tu che è
buono io ti mando fuori da questa casa
vi faccio vedere al volo quale secondo
me l'assetto migliore per questo
procedimento barriere piattino nuova ha
grattato
in questo modo potete prendere buttare
nell'uovo e mettere poi nel piattino
ascolare da cui poi passate subito il
pangrattato coprirlo di pangrattato e da
qui spostarli in due secondi sul
tagliere
nel quale poi fare la mia grande mossa
che ho copiato e rubato da giallo
zafferano
non può per il mare la scelta del genere
già mese viene male ti vengo a cercare
casa così come sono adesso liquidiamo in
frigo per mezz'ora e aspettiamo passata
mezz'ora rifacciamo la stessa cosa
solamente con uovo e pangrattato uovo
pangrattato sempre il procedimento del
contagio vengono più belli semplicemente
c'è anche meno possibilità che la
mozzarella resca va beh senza fa vedere
tutto quanto ne impariamo tutti no e
come dico sempre se ci riescono e ci può
riuscire chiunque a questo punto li
riprendiamo e altre zone in frigo ma
guglielmo a quello che un'incrostazione
di molto tempo fa mela vogliamo regole
si lascia di debito un tegamino con
dell'olio massa e riccò ma che cos'è è
la nostra fondi questo non mi pare
l'odore che c'era dei ristoranti di
parigi
mi raccomando ragazzi fiamma minimi per
evitare di farlo bruciare attaccare
sotto a sapore e basta enrico basta
ormai è così la scorsa montare così così
sarà per sempre
accendiamo prendiamo il nostro
termometro e arriviamo 170 gradi non so
se dello stato ma col termometro stava
trattando
sì ci stanno delle croste che mamma mia
io non so se salutare questa cosa anche
se ci metti dentro non lo so un batterio
è morto a 170 gradi ma una roba
veramente raccapricciante
guarda come cavolo che aleggiano questi
cosi dell'olio carico tutti sta
divertendo a fare questa cosa lascia in
pace l'incrostazione eccoci sappiamo
saprà di bruciato questo mamma mia di
sicuro saprà di polemiche se continui a
parlarci sopra al siviglia
per la rilassante procedesse mr
inconsapevolmente perché
inconsapevolmente mi sembra abbastanza
consapevole che è sono venuti pazzeschi
e ragazzi finiamo di cucinarli tutti
quanti e passiamo all'assaggio aspetto
io do 818 rustico anche sia chiaro cioè
un tipo di ricetta che vedo fatta da una
donna è l'aspetto e sette e mezzo sette
e mezzo allora aspetto è bello un bell 8
pieno se lo merita il piatto si è
svuotato nel frattempo il suo 77 e mezzo
io non glielo leva nessuno
con otto e mezzo o due ottime mammane a
freddo perfetto perfetto bravo di cosa
solo bravo odore odore odore buono
proprio di fritto quello bello ma sì per
quanto riguarda l'odore non a tutti
potrà piacere relatori di dritto ma
secondo me è la fine del mondo otto meno
dai odore di fritto ruolo ma non
follemente buono 7 sapone io sono uno
chef procedo all'assaggio ma che bella
consistenza e sapore acquisito cento ma
riuscire a mangiarmi di tutti e poi deve
mangiare mele altri lodando il voto al
sapore
sapore auto più allora questi abbiamo
una media precisa dell'otto proviamo col
sapore buonissimo un sapore e la cosa
migliore
8 contro il costo assolutamente ma cosa
supreme un euro e mezzo per questo sono
disposto a pagarne 15 con tutto questo
settecento quanto spenderei per ogni
singola cappellina 3 euro onesto quanto
spenderebbe tutto il piatto no ma ora
grazie io lo venderei doppio alla modica
cifra di 3 euro anche per questo piatto
pagherei un euro 1 euro e 50 al pezzo
ragazzi sarete questo video prima di
salutarci meno proposti una sfida
abbiamo un green screen qua dietro in
questo momento in blue screen
rimaniamo così rimaniamo così un secondo
poi avete la possibilità di scegliere da
oggi cosa vorreste che venga proiettato
dietro mandate un'immagine enrico punto
scilla chiocciola uniud.it dicendo
mettila nello sfondo di latina di gian
marco mete a sfondo regoliamo o di
arrivo e se fare questa cosa per la
possibilità di modificare il montaggio
potete inviare qualsiasi foto basta
essere una buona risoluzione ma potete
veramente inventarvi qualsiasi cosa ha
detto ciò mi scrivete a questo canale se
lo avete già fatto al tema della
campanella per le notifiche fateci
sapere cosa vorreste vedere in futuro
curdo fateci sapere cosa vorrebbe
rinculo all'impero di questo canale ci
vediamo giovedì prossimo alle 12 con un
nuovo video ciao